All right.
Greetings, Takuya. Hi.
You can mute the live
stream or turn off the other live
stream, but yeah, thank you for joining.
Yes, thank you for inviting thank you
for it. Yeah, it.
Well, we have a
little bit 35 or 38 minutes,
so it would be awesome to have your
presentation.
Great. So the
moment well,
can you see my.
I saw PowerPoint.
Okay. Can you
see my screen? Perfect.
Okay. So shall we start?
Yes. Thank you.
Then. Thank you for organizing
this wonderful symposium.
Today I'd like to talk about
relationship between canonical neural
network and active inference
and possible extension for
modeling social and shared intelligence
using canonical neural network. So let's
start.
As you know, the free energy principle
is proposed by Karl Friston that states
that perception, learning and action of
all biological organisms are determined
to minimize variational free energy as a
tractable proxy for surprise
minimization. And by this process
organism can perform parational BJ
inference or external mineral state.
And this can't even just show one
example typical set up under the free
energy principle active inference. Here
there is a hidden state in the external
world and only a part of this state can
be observable.
For our agent, this doc
and this transformation is done by
genetic model parameterized by theta
and to infer the hidden state,
agent need to reconstruct the
copy of the external state called
posterior relief. And this optimization
is done by minimizing variational free
energy. And parameter is
also optimized by minimizing free energy
to obtain an apt generative model to
represent this relationship. An
interesting aspect of the free energy
principle active inference is its
application to the optimization of
action. Here our agent have some
preference prior c and to obtain this
observation in the future, agent may
select the action that minimize
the expected free energy in the future
to obtain the most predictable outcome.
And finally, by selecting actions that
minimize the expect frequency, it can
obtain the feed. So, this is a typical
setup under active inference. But
question is what is the neural
neurosurge that can implement this
process? So that is our interest and
to address this issue we propose theory
as follows. Here we consider that
external world is parameterized
characterized by a set of the variables
like this here, this is a posterior
expectation and the S indicates the
hidden state in the external world.
Delta indicate the action of the agent
or decision and the theta indicate
a parameter and lambda is a
hyperparameter. So those set
of parameters or variables characterize
a generative model and free
energy variational. Free energy is
defined as a function of the sequence of
observation and external state and its
minimization indicates the variational
Bayesian inference.
Similarly, we consider a dynamics of
neural network and we consider that
dynamics is characterized by a set of
those variables. Here x indicates the
neuroactivity firing rate at middle raya
neurons and y indicate neuroactivity
of output raya neurons and W here is a
synaptic weight and phi is any other
free parameter that characterize neural
network. And we consider that neural
network dynamics is characterized by
minimization of some cost function l.
This is a function of the O and Phi
internal state of neural network and its
minimization indicates the generation of
neural network dynamics including both
activity and plasticity.
And our theory indicates equivalence
between those two functions.
Meaning that for any neural network that
minimize some cost function error,
there is a generative model that satisfy
if we call error. Which means that
the recapturation of external
dynamics is an inherent feature of any
neural system that follow such dynamics.
So this is an interesting prediction but
too abstract. So I would like
to introduce some analytically tractable
example to understand this relationship
formally. So first we
consider a very simple architecture.
This is represented by POMDP without
any state transition. So hidden state s
is simply generated by priya
distribution D and it
is a binary state.
But we consider a vector of binary
state, so it is a factory
of structure and observation
is also a binary vector and
the transformation from S to O is
characterized by categorical
distribution using likelihood
of matrix A and variational
Bayesian inference indicates the
inversion of this generative process
like this. So by solving the appropriate
frequency functional we obtain those
posterior brief that is optimal
in the Bayesian sense.
On the other hand, for neural network we
consider such structure here upper part
indicates the generation of signal in
the external world and the neural
network comprises only single layer.
Here activity of output layer are
generated by weighted sum of sensory
input O weighted by synaptic
matrix W. And we then characterize this
neural network in the next slide.
So to model neural network
or neuron, we start from
considering hodgeken hacksray equation
which comprises four differential
equation and this is a very complicated
non linear equation although it
is barely possible. So we consider some
reduction of these equations. So a
typical reduction method is
like this for example, m here is
much faster than other variables so this
can be repressed with its fixed point
or it is known that h and minus
one sorry, it is known that h and
one minus SN have
similar dynamics. So we can consider
a new effective variable U to
characterize those two variables and
then we obtain 2D hoskin hacks ray
equation like this. So this is a famous
cross of neural network model which
includes the well known Fitzfuel Nagamo
model or other continuous
neural network model and we modify
those model to derive canonical
neural model. So this is a definition of
canonical neural network model. Here
leak current is characterized by imbass
sigmoid function instead of cubic
function which is adopted in the
Fitzfuel Nagmo model. And we also
consider connection synaptic connection
and this part indicates synaptic input
from sensory layer through weight
matrices and 1 may consider
that W one indicate excitatory synapse
and W zero indicate inhibitory synapse
and the threshold are adaptive
thresholds that are function of W one
and W zero. Interestingly,
when we consider a fixed point of this
differential equation we obtain well
known red coding model with the
Sigmoidal activation function.
Which means that we can say that in some
sense this canonical neural network
network model is approximation
of Hodgkin hatt's ray equation and its
approximation level is,
in some sense between the realistic
model and the most simplified red coding
model. So we basically consider this
type of neural network model and in
the next slide we consider what
is the plausible cost function for
this neural network model. So again
we write the same equation
for canonical neural network model which
represents the activity of neurons
vector of neurons and we
consider cost function for this
differential equation which can be
obtained by simply calculating the
integral of right hand
side of this equation and get this
type of cost function for neural
network. This is biologically plausible
cost function in the sense that its
derivative derived neural network
activity which has a certain biological
plausibility. Moreover,
if we consider derivative of this cost
function with respect to synaptic weight
W, we obtain a conventional
synaptic plasticity rule which follows
Hebian law.
On the other hand, for Bayesian
inference we first define generality
model like the previous
slide and we
then derive variational free energy for
given genetic model. So this variation
of free energy is derived from the
Pom DP model in the previous
slide and its minimization indicates
the Beijing inference and running.
So we found formal
correspondences between component
of those two cost functions like
this. So this broke
vector formally correspond to this Brock
vector that represent a posterior
expectation and this logarithm
correspond to this logarithm and
actually this a matrix can
be represented as the broke matrix like
this and its dot product
correspond to this computation.
And finally, this phi naturally
correspond to this log d logo state
prior. Which means that because
the cost function are same, its
derivative provides
its derivative provides sorry.
Because the cost function are formally
equivalent, its derivative sorry.
It's a result of derivative
also corresponding each other.
Which means that for any neural activity
equation in this form, there is a
corresponding Bayesian inference
equation. This is an equation that
compute the posterior belief of the
hidden state and this synaptic practice
equation formally correspond to learning
or parameter of genetic model.
And moreover, by establishing this
relationship we can consider the reverse
engineering of the generality model from
empirical data here this schematic
summarize our approach to reverse
engineer generative model and we first
record the neural activity and assign
the canonical neural network to explain
this obtained data. And by computing the
integral we obtained a cost function for
this canonical network. And by the
mathematical equivalence we established,
we can automatically identify genetic
model and variational free energy that
correspond to this neural network
architecture. So interestingly, this is
a Bayesian agent which
is a kind of artificial intelligence.
But importantly, this artificial
intelligence is formally derived from
empirical data. So we can say that this
agent is biomimetic artificial
intelligence that follow the free energy
principle and then its derivative with
respect to parameter posterior
derived synaptic plastic algorithms
that follow the free energy minimization
and its time integral can predict
the running process of original neural
network data. Which means
that if the frequency principle is
correct, then this prediction should
work, should work and should
be able to predict the result of this
neural neta without referencing
to the data itself.
So our strategy is in
summary, our strategy is that we
reconstruct generative model only from
the initial data,
like initial data before running
and then predict the running process or
running curve that this
neural system should follow by
using the frequency principle and
compare or examine whether this
prediction is correct by comparing
actual data after running and the
prediction by the free energy principle.
And if this prediction is correct, then
it indicates the predictive validity of
the free energy principle under setup
considered. So we apply
this strategy to the in vitro neural
network. So here, this in vitro neural
network are stimulated using the POMDP
generative process defined in
the previous slide. So there are two
hidden sources that are binary signals
and they are
mixed to generate 32
sensory stimuli. Those are also binary.
And this is an overview of experiment
by stimulating in vitro neurons they
generate spiking response and those
rhyme indicate a high density spiking
response. So we observed that in
some neuron the
response specificity is so
we found that for some neuron response
was high to source one
signal compared to source two signal.
And if we see the transition
of those neurons, we found
that although we removed
the offset at the first session
to set those activities zero,
but we see that those
neuron self organized to respond high
when source one is one,
but those neurons response low
level when the source one
is zero. So which means that those
neurons activity, those neurons response
was consistent with
our theoretical prediction that
neuroactivity cell organized to encode
the posterior expectation of healing
state. And we also found that some other
group of neuron responds preferentially
to source two but not to source one.
So then we ask okay,
then we found that posterior
expectation is encoded by neuroactivity
and the next question is about other
neuronal substrate and we
then ask if the prior
brief about hidden state is effectively
equal to the firing threshold of
neural activity model, neural network
model. So if the theory is correct,
this correspondence should exist.
To check this, we first simulated
a Bayern agent and when we
varied the PRI of the
Bayesian agent, the inference was
attenuated as I expected.
And we found that when we buried
the excitatory level of in vitro neural
network by using the pharmacological
manipulation. We also found that the
attenuation of inference which
is consistent with our theoretical
prediction that firing threshold encode
prior belief or the hidden state.
And next we consider whether the
scientific plasticity followed the free
energy principle by asking whether
free energy principle can predict the
qualitative self organization of a
subsequent neural data.
So here we model neural
network like this, there are two
ensemble neurons that encode source one
and source two. And we first compute
the effective synaptic weight of
those networks using
a conventional connection strength
estimation approach and plot those
synaptic weights on the landscape
of theoretically computed free energy.
So this is a trajectory of empirically
estimated synaptic weights effective
sign optic connectivity and as
predicted, those changes reduce
the free energy.
And here we computed this
theoretically predicted free energy
landscape only using the past ten
sessions data. So that this indicates
that indicates some prediction
of the self organization.
And for more explicit prediction,
we then simulated neuroactivity
and plasticity using green as a
principle. Here the
brighter color indicates the prediction
of data without reference
to activity data. So those
lines exactly follow this free
energy gradient. And we found
that this predicted trajectory
is tightly correlated
with this empirically estimated
effective synaptic weights.
And LR rate is like this.
So it indicates that frequency
principle can quantitatively predict
the circumstance in this setup, so it
indicates some predictive validity of
the free energy principle under this
setup. And then we also consider
the modeling of the neuromodulation
using active inference. It is well known
that synaptic process is modified by
various factors like Dopamine, northern
adrenaline, acetylcholine, serotonin,
so on. And one interesting property
of those moderation is that even though
Dopamine was added after
associative plasticity was established,
it can change the result of plasticity
in a post hoc or restorespective manner,
so it implies
some association to the reward and
past decisions. So we model this process
using canonical neural network. So here
we model the post
hoc modulation of HEBM plasticity
using this type of
plasticity equation and we also consider
the recurrent neural network structure
and output layer for this network.
And we consider that modulation occur at
this connectivity layer.
And then we found cost
function that can derive those
differential equations and then found
corresponding variational free energy
and genetic model which means that
this sort of neural network activity
including moderation of sinus plasticity
exactly follow the free energy principle
under some type of homodp
generative model. And by using this,
we show that this biologically
plausible neural network model with
moderation of heavy and plasticity can
solve some sort of delayed
reward task like maze task.
And then finally we would like to
discuss a possible extension to this
framework to the modeling social
intelligence. So,
to infer our con specifics,
we need to select an appropriate
generality model for our partners,
depending on our partners. So this can
be done by Beijing model selection
scheme and we previously proposed a
model that can predict the multiple
biosomes using one
big genetic model that comprises
multiple genetic models. And this
movie shows prediction of
prediction of songs.
So like this, this model
nicely identified which
genetic model is the best to explain a
given sensory input. And this process
indicates and the
model can correctly infer the
appropriate model and then imitate
the song by its own action.
So, although in the previous work we
didn't discuss a detailed neural
neural substrate for this mixture
generative model, we now be able to
consider the corresponding
circuit architecture. For example, if we
consider the moderation of neural
module by neuromodulator like Dopamine,
it act as an attentional filter.
And this attentional filter can be
explained by three factor
Hebian running rule introduced
in the previous slide. So again,
this modulation works
as the post hoc moderation plasticity.
And this modulation can optimize
each model to represent one generative
model, one generate one song in
a mutually independent manner.
So, through this process, it is possible
to learn multiple generative model
in a vertically plausible manner. So,
in summary, we found that the dynamics
of kinetic neural network that minimize
a cost function can be read as
minimization of variational free energy.
It indicates free energy principle is an
apt explanation for this type of neural
network. And we also validate
this prediction using some in vitro
setup by
showing that free energy principle can
quantitatively predict the self
organization of subsequent plasticity
only using the initial data.
And as the modeling, we can extend
those canonical network modeling to
the action generation as a planning
via the delayed moderation of heavy
emperor's DST. And finally, we discuss
possibility to extend this canonical
model to modeling the
social or shared intelligence ah
to interact with multiple partners.
So, that's all of my talk. Thank you for
listening. This is Acknowledgment. Our
collaborator and fundings and our unit
are now recruiting postdoc
researchers. So if you're interested,
please check.
Awesome. Thank you for the presentation,
Takuya. I'll just
ask a few quick questions from the live
chat and a few other things that come
up. So Dave says Takuya
used the phrase after plasticity was
established. Was his group able to
modify e g increase plasticity?
Or is he saying merely that it was shown
that there is plasticity?
Yeah, I'm not sure if I understand
correctly your question, but those
groups show that Dopamine adding
Dopamine after 2 seconds after
the association occurred can
change the
magnitude of plasticity. So without how
to say if Dopamine
addition was before this
association, then plasticity level is
low. But after Dopamine
addition after association can change
this level can increase the plasticity
like this or like this which
indicates the post hook moderation.
Cool. I think that answers it.
Well, what are you excited
for? Or what are your hopes or
feelings on where the active inference
ecosystem is at and where we're headed
in the coming months and years?
Sorry again chris,
just what are you excited about? Other
than your own research directions? What
are you excited about in the active
inference ecosystem? Yeah.
So, of course, one direction is
the modeling of social interaction,
which is much rich architecture
than the interaction between the static
environment. So if both agents run with
each other, then many interesting
phenomena can be observed. So we are
excited with modeling those
phenomena using biologically plausible
neural network model through this
equivalence.
Awesome. Any last comments?
Any other comments that you want to
make? Takuya.
Awesome. Thanks again for the
presentation. And people should check
out Live Stream 51, where you and I
talked a few other times and went into
some of the details on that work.
There's a lot there. It's really
exciting. Thank you.
All right, thank you. See you next time.
See you next time. Bye.
All right, the next session
is going to be with Shannon Dobson.
This section is going to be called Dark
Imaginarium Shared Intelligence as an
Infinity Curiosity type message.
Shannon, make sure that everything's
good with the audio.
Wow.
Great talk so far.